all right still sick but doing my Star
Wars rising Skywalker spoiler tuck and
that's a spoiler warning if you haven't
seen Star Wars the rise of Skywalker you
probably shouldn't watch this so there's
a lot to talk about again this is like
most spoiler talks I do isn't gonna be a
play-by-play but there's more to talk
about in here than a lot of my other
spoiler videos so we're just gonna get
right into it and if you find it
difficult to take a grown man and a Star
Wars shirt and a bathrobe seriously well
can help you so what you get today so
alright as the movie starts out it says
the dead speak I guess Palpatine sent
out some forced voicemail announcing to
the galaxy I'm back [ __ ] so he's back
and now everyone knows he's back which
is actually pretty dumb why'd he do that
even when Voldemort came back he was
like I mean I'm packed but I'm just
gonna let my goons know that I'm back
and not really a lot of other people so
no one will believe the little brat who
says I'm back that's smart
Palpatine announcing it to everyone it's
not too smart cuz that eliminates the
possibility of people having doubt what
have been so much cooler if certain
people found out Palpatine's back and
other people were like [ __ ] come
live they can't be bad but immediately
the movie starts out in a montage where
kylo ren's just kind of cleaning house
and then he finds this little holocron
that's not a holocron that totally looks
like a Sith holocron I mean it's just a
sip device that has Sith information but
it's not a holocron fine and I also read
a couple comments where people were like
but Star Wars always starts out at the
end of another situation which I kind of
disagree with but kind of agree with it
does but that's every situation the
beginning of any situation is also the
end of another situation that's just
kind of how it works but when a movie
starts out with a montage that's just
cleaning up the end of an act I I just
feel like we missed something don't
worry there will be a book promise so
anyhow kylo Ren wants to find Palpatine
to take him down because he's like no
one's gonna threaten my power
tallip it seems like but of course kylo
Ren has his own plans he wants to get
Rey and Thursdays gonna rule the galaxy
together with the scavenger hunt I'm not
really gonna go too much into this Gavin
ran up the stone Leia scavenger complete
with the dagger that shows where
something is which what's up with that
dagger like I'm totally down with the
little item that shows you the location
of a super secret ancient thing but when
it's this item that shows you the
location of something among
forty-year-old wreckage Goodin takes the
mysticism out of it's like
talking thousands or hundreds of years
ago pointing to something that's in 40
year old garbage sure you're not exactly
calling Indiana Jones here it doesn't
belong in a museum but there's a spy in
the first order guess who it is tend to
tell that reveal I'm the spy of course
you are Huck's what else would you be
doing we should actually could have been
a cool arc about as cool as a
stormtrooper turning good and they're
about to waste out as much as they did
waste that because the newer much cooler
commander just shoots Hux in the chest
is all right you're dead now we found
the spy moving on because again damage
control I see that a lot in this movie
the last Jedi made calls and now this
movie has to do damage control for it
Huck's could have been an awesome
commander they would have built him up
in the last Jedi but instead Rian
Johnson was like now let's just smack
him around funny right all right well
now no one fears Huck so we might as
well kill him and bring someone else in
it completely wasted hugs
I said Reyes o P in this movie and she
is Opie like [ __ ] she's more open here
than she's ever been she was already
Opie you know what I realized of the
core Star Wars heroes like the manes
Luke Anakin
red ray is the only one who never took
damage at first I was like well she's
the only one who never lost a hand or an
arm and then I thought about it I'm like
she never actually took damage there's
that one scene where snoke's holding her
in the air and she's screaming it's the
most damage she really ever takes no
limbs nothing he's just huh Oh P I mean
even Finn got his [ __ ] spine slashed
and then after that didn't do much he
was he was the friend also this is a
movie where everyone dies and comes back
well not everyone but it happens more
than a few times where someone dies and
then comes back like when Ray is holding
the ship with the force because you know
she's that powerful
she's holding and then she with reflex
shoots the force lightning and blows up
the ship that supposedly Chuy's in
you're like holy [ __ ] - Chewie just died
a couple scenes later it's revealed not
Chewie didn't die but it's kind of a
weird scene to me it's like you he's
dead and then also in the movie goes
psych but Chewy's not fake dead long
enough for it to actually be impactful
like Chewie
oh no he's not this one so why even give
me the psych-out it doesn't matter in
c-3po died and then he came back his
memory was wiped which I mean in one
hand you're like so c-3po and all his
memories from the original trilogy now
he's essentially dead he's a new droid
now but that actually happened at the
end of the prequel
so he's been mindwiped before but for a
moment there I was like c-3po he just
legit kylo Ren fake dies like three
times
he fights right and then Leia like you
know distracts him which actually Leia
was done very well untimely tragedy with
Carrie Fisher they had very little to
work with and so they actually of the of
the limits they had the Carrie Fisher
thing was actually pulled off very well
distracts kylo Ren and then raced stabs
kylo Ren at first I was like Oh kylo
Ren's dead now yeah she for it's so
rakin force here which I don't have a
problem with the concept of force he'll
that's that's been in Star Wars
especially the games you played the Star
Wars mmo's Old Republic or whatever like
force Hales inability you can heal with
the force I totally get that but the
fact that she's so new that she could
just heal with the force that's that's
weird where did she learn that Luke
didn't teach her cuz Luke doesn't come
to her again until here in the last Jedi
he didn't teach her jack-shit
sort of Leia teacher may because lay can
fly through outer space maybe she taught
her to forcefield yes Leia has been
training her in the forest even though
Leia dipped out on training decades ago
that's actually thing that flew over my
head in the force awakens when she
forced manipulated the stormtrooper
people were like how does she know how
to do that I had already made my videos
and then I heard that I was like how did
she and so now I look for that I look
for things that people know with the
force that's like how do they know how
to do that his movie has a couple any no
she forced heels kylo Ren goes away and
then kylo Ren slit he's really
conflicted then he here hey kid and I
actually thought it was Luke Skywalker
and I was like oh it's lo ho whoa it's
Han like Harrison Ford actually came
back in that CGI like I would have
probably put money on that he would have
been if I heard Han Solo was in this
movie you know he gives kylo Ren a pep
talk and the talk was actually good that
that moment is actually a good moment I
love a good father/son moment what can I
say I'm mushy like that even uses the
same lines but it's like I know what I
need to do but I don't know if I have
the strength to do it show me that
turning good is as hard as turning bad
just like taking that step out of where
you are is just a hard thing and that's
fair that was actually a good moment
also two things I want to know how much
that paycheck was but I know how big
that paycheck was I brought errors and
forward-back that guy doesn't even get a
[ __ ]
the fact that he's even in this is he
can retire now I have to assume but also
that's got to be the single most
important cameo in the whole thing like
it's the whole thing cuz they're gonna
turn kylo Ren good and turn him back
into Ben solo you need his dad also the
person he killed to give the okay to
sign off on it so we can accept it cuz
if you don't have his murder dad saying
guy audience it's okay I forgive him
he's my son you should then Rogers gonna
be like [ __ ] that [ __ ] that we're
not gonna buy it so for the movie that's
actually a really important cameo so I
hope Disney wrote him a very big check
however Han Solo wasn't a Jedi so he was
a memory he's I kind of took it like
Dumbledore and Harry Potter I have so
many Harry Potter comparisons I don't
know why okay I took it as a Dumbledore
thing with Harry Potter where it was
like it's is it a memory or a
hallucination point is but the words
speak to the person so it's real to them
however in reality it's Disney going we
need you Harrison we need you because
Kyle is gonna do important stuff when
he's good he's not though what Ben solo
does in this movies he takes out the
Knights of Ren who were also very
[ __ ] useless the Knights of Ren
jack-shit that's what they are they're
nothing it feels like the Knights of Ren
were ever created to give Ben solo
something to take down and he does after
the Knights of Ren don't do jack [ __ ] he
just kind of takes down the Knights of
Ren and this is the most important thing
it's all led to this he and Ray have one
of the most Awkward kisses ever in Star
Wars - four - and the awkward kiss scale
good job Disney Star Wars spinnin rows
ray and been equally awkward it just
felt like why a novel [ __ ] I was
like I thought we were over this the
young adult novels Jon I thought that
was dead I forgot Luke comes back so ray
goes to the Jedi Temple planet that Luke
was on and last Jedi he's throwing wood
on the fire and she throws a lightsaber
and Luke's ghost hand grabs it and he's
like this should be treated with respect
last Jedi you hear that like this
totally a jab at last she was like well
you came here and II was like I was
wrong the point is Palpatine's back and
when you see Palpatine it's actually
really neat you know the flickering
light he looks like a ghoul he looks
like something out of a horror movie
and the movie doesn't really explain how
he's back just that he's back and even
used the lion dog side of the force is a
pathway to many abilities some consider
to be natural
good job using that line from the old
movies just kind of validate the fact
that's like well it's unnatural and
you're around whatever done ask is
because he learned Darth Plagueis way of
living forever
is he a clone it looks like he's cloning
Snoke or maybe Snoke is a creation
because he learned how to create life
with the medic lorian's I say the word
that's just the Lord because that was
dumb why so Snoke is some sort of
creation of Palpatine roundup creation
clone or otherwise point is you see
Stokes body and he has so many scars
he's all twisted and messed up you like
there's a story there no the story is
cloning as a hell of a thing it's hard
sometimes the bodies are they're messed
up oh well that's just much less
interesting so basically Snoke is one of
the twisted fucked-up failed versions of
Ripley and Alien Resurrection Thapa teen
was like good enough let's just go ahead
and rebuild the forces I mean granted I
already have my fleet hidden in ice
falls to prosper and ya know this movie
does not have a Death Star I guess every
Star Destroyer is a Death Star I mean
the Death Star is a big deal it's a big
special thing it took decades to make
and that's actually the leap I have to
take for Return of the Jedi is the fact
that he just kind of made another Death
Star but now every Star Destroyer has
destined it's a Death Star now which
really means jack [ __ ] it doesn't do
anything for the movie it's like ooh
there's a big threat yeah Palpatine is
also a big threat you can just have him
go ahead and be the threat why do you
need miniaturized Death Star tech on
Star Destroyers and how how I get tech
gets smaller and more powerful as time
goes on and get it I feel like that
would have been the conversation at the
roundtable where someone should have
just drawn the line to like no more
Death Star's
anything else but Death Star's I guess
what if planets don't blow up
it doesn't feel threatening enough which
you find out in this movie Palpatine
needs energy he can SAP force energy or
life force from people and that's how
he's gonna become complete he's gonna be
Palpatine Prime now before that he's
just kind of he has no pupils and he
looks like he's hooked up to glados's
body from Portal so when Ray and Ben
solo were there he saps their life force
and becomes he's a complete Palpatine
now so Palpatine saps the life force
from Ray and Ben and he becomes
Palpatine as as we knew him which
actually I did like the red lining in
his robe that was cool-looking but also
he is
patinas we knew him all messed up
Palpatine the how though because
supposedly his face got scarred when
mace windu deflected the Force Lightning
back onto his face which means that
Palpatine gets recreated or cloned or
whatever this is he should look like
that like if I have a startup face and
you cloned me my clones not gonna have
the sky regardless he shoots a bunch of
Force Lightning into the air and blasts
a huge chunk of this fleet but he shoots
the force lightening a train rages
blocks it blocks it likes nothing this
what I'm talking about when I say opie
is not just the force heeling it's the
fact that he shot of force lightning
that eradicated a section of the fleet
arrays like boom blocked I got this how
do you got this
there is a line repel patís like I am
all this if and you were all the Jedi so
is she literally she has the powers of
all the Jedi she must because then she
deflects the force lightning back to
Palpatine which instead of being smart
and Palpatine's like I I recognize
what's happening I'm not gonna do this
again mace windu did this exact same
thing to me stop in the force lightning
before it kills me but she deflects it
back and I know those old books old
canon it's been wiped away which this
just shows why the old canon is just I
like it more because it had rules
because that ability to deflect force
lightning that's something mace windu
knew how to do and he deflected it back
at Palpatine it just created some
feedback loop that just messed him up
that's how it messed him up but I guess
she just knows how to do that very
specific ability how no one was alive
who could have taught her that
but again the line works like I am all
the Sith you are all the Jedi because
apparently we're in the plot of the
movie the one with Jet Li I did like
that force moment where she's looking up
at the stars and you hear all the voices
cuz you're like oh that's that's totally
mace windu that's samuel l.jackson oh
that's quite on J and there is Liam
Neeson I heard from someone that you
hear Anakin Skywalker say bring balance
as I did which is the Hawaii being like
look it's not that he didn't bring
balance that she's also gonna do it now
maybe that's their way of explaining how
she could do mace windu sting but it
just it just shows me what it just it
proves the point that you feel like the
conversation at the round table was like
look guys we have the force we can do
anything
whereas Lucas would have been like look
we have the force but it's not like we
can just do anything the difference in
mindset right there and so yeah she
deflects it back to Palpatine vaporizes
him no problem and she goes to Tatooine
buries the lightsaber creates her own
lightsaber because toys and someone's
like
what's your name it she's like Ray Ray
who she sees Luke and Leia and she goes
Skywalker the part of me that thinks it
would have been cooler to be like
Palpatine but people know the name
Palpatine that had been like oh really
ya know we're gonna kill you before you
cause a problem so one half of me gets
it the other half though it's that would
have been the greatest slap in the face
to Palpatine to be like no now the name
Palpatine is a name for good your legacy
as you wanted to build it is dead but I
mean cooler you know but I guess she's a
Skywalker now she was so bonded with
Luke Skywalker and his grumpy ass let's
Jedi that means so much to her I mean
Skywalker means a lot to us I just don't
feel like the name meant as much to
raise I don't know why she took it on
accept the fact that it means a lot to
us uh I forgot to really elaborate I'm
raised a palpitate raised a palpitate
are we just gonna not talk about the
fact that Palpatine had a kid Palpatine
had a kid who then had a kid like
Palpatine's a grandpa I mean did he have
a wife obviously he got down did he have
sex when you look like that or when you
look like that look in the end this
movie makes me think of the whole
trilogy itself it's like have a path
know where you're going to go and if
you're gonna bring the big baddie from
the previous story back illustrate that
earlier then you know the third movie
and I'm telling you that's how you can
see it's like they didn't know they were
gonna do that like in the Lord of the
Rings trilogy you know for the whole
trilogy what they're fighting for is
keeping sour on from coming back and if
Palpatine was going to come back they
should have Illustrated that in the
first movie you can have this jackoff
named Snoke be the one who turned kylo
Ren and then he gets killed in the first
movie that like oh we're done the evil
is dead and then Palpatine's little
message goes out at the end of the movie
cut to credit so the second movie
they're like we need to stop him from
coming back third movie he comes back
and now we really have problems or
something like that granted I don't
think George Lucas would have wanted
that and bringing him back [ __ ] me
alright new lighting lighting is a
little different actually it looks a
little more epic here through the
circuit breaker in my filming room and
it just won't go back like I just can't
turn the circuit breaker back on so I
gotta call a technician rather than burn
my house down and move everything into
my bedroom and now we've finished the
video in here sure guys to the end of
this thing I totally forgot to talk
about the fact that Leia and Ben solo
they both died Leia dies after
distracting Ben solo Ben solo dies after
the whole confrontation with Palpatine
then they both disappear which means
they become one with the force which
Leia I can by Benson
did he know how to do that he turned bad
so young in life I feel like that
takes a little longer to do don't know
why I guess he did but in the end I've
said most of what I'm gonna say is
Disney Star Wars trilogy it's a
testament to have a plan have all the
producers directors writers in a room
the roundtable discussion ago okay
what's the plan for the entire trilogy
that's why I like this Disney Star Wars
trilogy in the end it made me appreciate
the prequels more because though they
are flawed
they are the vision of a person who knew
where it was going this consistency
there it actually has good lore just not
great script but good lord most
importantly it feels like a Star Wars
adventure funny enough if I look at the
rise of Skywalker as its own thing like
it's the only thing that happened after
Return of the Jedi it was Return of the
Jedi 40 years later this new crew and
the Emperor's coming back to this new
crew we've never met before they have to
stop them it's probably not too bad it's
just a one time adventure a one-off but
that's not the case it's a trilogy it's
a trilogy that really it was at war with
itself it just played tug-of-war duty
Abrams pulling it this way Rian Johnson
pulled it that way JJ Abrams now has to
spend time pulling it back that way and
if you're playing tug of war you're not
gaining any ground so don't blame Abrams
he did the best with what he could
really if I'm looking at it and I'm
being honest the concept of a trilogy
it's a tradition also three is a magic
number with Star Wars trilogies have
just always been the way but I don't
think there would have been any shame in
having a tenth movie being like look
instead of a trilogy we're gonna have
four movies in this saga because well
damage control we got to make up a lot
of ground there were some wrenches
thrown in the gears and so we just have
to spend a movie cleaning that up then
we'll wrap it up instead you have Raisa
Skywalker trying to do two things and be
three movies and when we reach the end
you have the Emperor like strike me down
and my essence will possess your body
and I guess I know like if we're doing
deep cuts if we're going deep into the
lore of the Sith there's this essence
transfer power that Sith have done but
we haven't seen that in the movies and
it doesn't feel like they're paying
homage to the old powers it feels like
they're just scrambling and trying to
create a scenario that'll turn ray bad
with no setup just seems like a rush job
you can't just go Palpatine's alive
somehow he created Snoke he's been every
voice kylo ren's ever heard in his head
he has a fleet of stardestroyers that
have been hidden
all of them have death star style
cannons attached to them raise all the
Jedi I am all the Sith and if she kills
me I transfer my essence and evil into
her and have your answer because Star
Wars these are the biggest leaps that
have ever happened in a Star Wars movie
the movie just doesn't do a good job of
conveying how I'll say this if I'm
talking trilogies I think The Matrix
Revolutions finished off the Matrix
trilogy better than Star Wars the rise
of Skywalker finished off to Disney Star
Wars trilogy and if this is closing the
book on the Skywalker saga this is how
the Skywalker saga ends not with a bang
but a whimper not for me it just ends on
Endor I guess that's a big reason that
bummed me out because you know when the
force awakens came out I was like oh
yeah right I get it little uh it's very
familiar but we're back on track and I
was just always hoping that we're gonna
pull it off and a lot of people out
there like they're not nah [ __ ] this and
I was like no no and then turns out well
they were right and if I can sum it up
in one sentence it's from the great
Woody from Toy Story thank you was it
flying that was falling with style
all right so Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker have you seen it what did you
think about it what did you like what
did you not like whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]